This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what
he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are talking about a pain, I think. A lot of us carry around in our 20s, but really at any age. At any age you can have this deep sadness and frustration around how to
I love again when I've been hurt so badly in the past? How do I love again when I have learnt that love is not something that I can trust? And just saying that there's so much hurt in those statements, there's so much pain and trauma in those statements. Especially when the love you've experienced in the past has been toxic, I think this goes beyond heartbreak. It goes beyond somebody, you know, you and somebody else just not working out. There is this reprogramming that occurs when you experience toxic love. It changes how you interpret every single detail, every single thing somebody does. It changes how you respond to closeness or even how safe you feel with somebody when they're kind to you and when they do everything right and when they are the one. It can just train
your body to even after a relationship is over associate love with panic and love with hostility so that when maybe one day you meet somebody who is very calm and lovely, instead of feeling bliss, and instead of feeling safe, you just feel suspicious and you just feel restless. Like you're waiting, you're waiting for the catch, you're waiting for something to go horribly wrong. I've been there myself in my relationship before I met Tom. you know, it really did something to me. It sometimes it felt like love was just something that could be manipulated and taken advantage of. That's what that relationship left me feeling.
And when I met Tom, those past experiences really caused me to be really suspicious, very suspicious. So I kind of wanted to, I don't know, reflect on my own experience in a way and bring that to this episode on experiencing healthy love after toxic love. What we're going to explore is what toxic love does to your nervous system, what it does to your self-esteem, to your biological wiring, to your attachment patterns, and then as well, how we can slowly, practically,
relearn how to feel safe and how to feel excited by the potential of a relationship. So without further ado, it's going to be a big episode. Strap in. Let's get into it. So the first big question of the day, what does toxic love actually look like? There is no Oxford Dictionary definition for this. I'm sure you guys probably don't even need me to describe it. You know what you felt it.
But it basically just represents a relational or a relationship dynamic that is consistently and insidiously harmful to your well-being. It's not necessarily about one person being evil or about the occasional argument. It is often about a pattern of things like chronic invalidation, emotional inconsistency, jealousy, contempt, nastiness, betrayal that makes you feel very small, and that there's just a part of you that feels,
even in those moments that this isn't how you're meant to be treated. In toxic relationships, there will likely be repeated cycles of rupture without repair or kind of emotional chaos that makes you feel destabilized and very insecure. It's never resolved. You just either stop thinking about it or you move on to the next thing. It's very intense. It's very time-consumption. emotionally consuming, and it's very hard to leave, not because you're scared,
although that can be a part of it, but sometimes just because you're really actually hooked on the highs and lows and kind of, in a way, you're addicted or you're hooked to this, like, potential. It's the hope that really kills you in these situations. It's the hope that keeps you hanging around, hope that it's going to get better, hope that it's going to transform into the thing you want it to be. You might be thinking, thinking, ah, a lot of, huh, a lot of that sounds like abuse, just with a less intense name. And that's a really valuable point. So let's quickly discuss the difference here. Abusive love or just straight up abuse, cut the love part, just abuse.
It's fundamentally about power and about control. It's, again, a pattern where usually one person's autonomy gets eroded over time. And the other person is the one who obviously does that erosion, but they monitor your phone, they isolate you from friends, they control your money, they make threats, they coerce you into things, they intimidate you, they emotionally punish you for any signs of independence. That's really what abuse looks like. And toxic love and abusive or just abuse can definitely overlap. But I think toxic love sits like a little, sits a little bit below. Some relationships are toxic but not abusive. It's just two people with poor boundaries, two people with poor conflict skills, lots of insecurity, lots of reactivity, people who hurt each other but aren't necessarily engaging in a pattern of domination. And some
relationships also worth acknowledging begin as toxic and then slide into abuse, slide into fear and control and coercion. But I think a lot of us live in that messy middle, relationships that are just tumultuous, where there's just true people whose needs and wants are different. And one person is really putting themselves more in the middle. And one person is really calling more of the shots, not to dominate you, maybe to dominate you, but more so just because there's a selfishness there and there's a lack of communication there. And it's just messy. And there's not a clear definition of what exactly is going wrong, but you know that something is. I think what's difficult is that we look at those kinds of situations.
And because they're not abusive, we don't want to sound dramatic or make too big of a deal of them or the way that they've impacted us, but they do still leave a mark. And toxic love leaves psychological wounds, pretty deep ones. It can really significantly change how you. you see love, especially if it is in your 20s. It's not something to kind of be brushed aside. Your 20s are already very much dictated by high change. They are, they are a high learning stage of life. People often think that childhood is our most malleable time. It definitely is for some things, but your relationship blueprint, you know,
continues to develop into adulthood. And especially in your 20s, it can be, it can be shifted rapidly when a relationship, I don't know how I can word this, but when it doesn't have a stable center, when it doesn't have a stable core, it can throw you off your mark and scramble what you think love should be. Basically, I think when two stories are being told about love at the same time in the same relationship, one where you feel good, and the second story where you feel terrible and they keep switching and you keep thinking this is amazing and I feel safe and then I feel exhausted and I feel dismissed and I feel like I'm not wanted and I feel terrible. They come into conflict and they clash and your brain only wants one story to be true. So it doesn't really know where to place what's going on and it doesn't
really know, I guess, how to adapt your expectations of love accordingly. There's just a lot going on that kind of scrambles our blueprint. The biggest impact of this is that it can lead us to normalize dysfunction and almost emotionally justify or emotionally rebrand a tumultuous kind of relationship as exciting, simply as a way to endure it. Meaning that eventually, again, when we do encounter this healthy, safe love, and it doesn't contain those rapid ups and downs, it can feel really boring because it contradicts what we've come to expect. Sometimes, you know, after chaos, and I've seen this in so many people's relationships
that I know. Stability feels really just dull, not because healthy love is dull, but because you've learned to associate love with intensity and with stimulation and excitement. These relationships include so many highs and so many lows, and that pattern is very similar to the pattern that most addictive substances rely on to get you hooked. This pattern of stress, intensity and then euphoria and relief at consuming the substance or experiencing the stimulus and then it eventually plummets back the relief is gone. You're scrambling for a higher dose. This is why toxic love and I think addiction sometimes go hand in hand. There is a real neurochemical level to it. It's exhausting but it's also familiar and more importantly
it can really interrupt and harm the part of your brain that deals with the interpretation of danger, that deals with fear, that deals with regulating heightened emotions. There's a concept in polyvagal theory called neuroception, which basically talks about how your body is constantly or unconsciously in a state where it can detect threats. So essentially, at any given time,
there is always a part of you that's going to be able to sense danger. The thing is, is that when people feel safe, that reaction, those reactions are downregulated. So they're not taking up all your mental, physical, cognitive resources. Your body's able to stay mobilized. You're able to stay in the present. You're able to feel safe. After trauma, after something like a really intense relationship, especially one that felt very harmful,
neuroception can become dysregulated. So you perceive danger and you perceive this intensity as the new normal. Even in safe situations, your body remains in that heightened state of alertness and that becomes basically your new equilibrium. Your new equilibrium is one whereby everything feels like at any given moment it could turn terribly wrong. And the research does show, again, just to nail this point home again, after experiencing relational trauma, people struggle because of neuroception
and because of many other processes, to read safety correctly. And often they will confuse safety with something else. A 2012 paper in the journal Neurophthalmicalogy actually suggests that people with PTSD, for example, struggle to, down regulate or switch off fear and anxiety responses. And so because this low level of anxiety becomes the new normal, when safe situations come along, sometimes those can actually feel the most scary
because they are so counter to what is familiar. Sometimes the healthy, safe relationship can feel the most bizarre and terrible and fearful because it's so different. it's so different from what you expect. You don't have to have experienced or have PTSD for this to be the case. My point is just that essentially when your brain has learned that in the relational context, closeness is dangerous. It becomes harder to feel safe even when you are safe because that doubt is your insurance.
And the feeling of safety is not normal and therefore feels unsafe, uncanny and so you interpret even the most harmless, wonderful situations as things that are threats. Someone predictable comes along, someone who doesn't play games, someone who is just really into you and you think this is a fanatastic. They give you all the reassurance you need, they give you everything you need, and then your nervous system cuts in and because it's so used to scanning and bracing and suddenly there is nothing wrong, that feeling of peace. is unfamiliar and that feeling of peace can feel I know I've said uncanny the most times but can be anxiety inducing in its own way so what that basically means is that after toxic love
you are approaching healthy love and the potential for healthy love with an entirely new perspective and with an entirely new I don't want to say brain but set of neurological and psychological habits that mean you can't and you feel like you cannot always trust your judgment of the person in front of you or your judgment of the situation you're in. There's also the combined element here of perhaps the chronic invalidation and the instability you most likely experienced in your last relationship that has probably conditioned you to distrust your own perceptions and experiences in these kind of dating scenarios. There's this weird, I guess, hindsight bias that occurs in these situations where we look at
the past knowing how it's turned out and we wonder why our past selves couldn't have foreseen this and didn't know, which is ridiculous because they hadn't lived yet. But this hindsight bias causes us to begin to question whether our judgment is broken. And therefore, as a result, it causes us to mistrust anyone and everyone in a kind of better, safe than sorry, I guess kind of way. It's honestly so twisted. It's so twisted that you have to experience this and that this is kind of, this is what love feels like now.
And I'm sorry, it's really, really sucky. I remember my boyfriend when we first started dating, I must have had some, I guess it must have been a work achievement. I can't remember. That's bad for me, but something really big it happened. And he sent me this, like, big box of sunflowers to my office. And this was when I had an office with some of my friends, some of my best friends. And they were all gushing. They were like, this guy is amazing. This guy is so great for you. And I was like, looking at these flowers, and I just couldn't help but think, like, what's this guy's angle? Like, what's this to go up to? What's he buttering me up for?
Like, look at this love bombing going on here. It was, it just, I feel like I was at that stage where I hadn't been with my ex for years. And in that moment, I had such a wave of anger towards him. Like, you're going to fuck this up as well. And you're not even here. Like, you have created these reactions and these patterns now in me. And am I going to sabotage this incredible thing because of you, like, because of the past? And there was definitely this distance between me and Tom in the early days.
And I'm so glad he could see that for what it was, which was not just interest, but caution. And I know a lot of people have a similar experience. This amazing person is in front of you and you're like, what's the catch? I guess what I'm saying is that after toxic love, really what it is is that having hope feels irresponsible. Because you had hope before and look where it got you. And it's not a nice feeling being that pessimistic. Because you probably weren't that pessimistic before this last person. You probably really believed in love.
And if you're going through that now, I know it can be very hard. It can be very hard to feel like either they're gaslighting you or your gaslighting yourself. But I promise it does most certainly get better. The other thing, and probably the final thing I'll touch on here, The other thing toxic relationships can do to you is that they literally change your attachment style. Even if you're an adult, even if you're in your 20s or you're in your 30s or your 40s, I know a lot of us try to categorize ourselves into three prescribed boxes. You're either anxious, you're avoidant or you're secure.
And we box ourselves into these based on how we like that. learned about relationships growing up. And we kind of assume, and we talk about our attachment style as though it's completely fixed and unchangeable after childhood. It's formed in childhood. It's impacted by childhood only. That's what the original theory by Bulby and Ainsworth says. And then once you're 18, you're locked in for life. If you're insecure, you're insecure for life. if you're secure, you're secure for life, and that's just the cards you're dealt. But your attachment style isn't fixed. It's actually influenced by relationship experiences across your life, across time.
And a toxic experience can shift your system radically, almost overnight. You know what's also really interesting? There's actually, I read this paper recently, there's research showing that attachment security and your attachment style can actually fluctuate not just day to day, but depending on the person that you're with. Essentially, your attachment style can be different just for one singular relationship, which sounds preposterous, but you could be secure in all other relationships, in your friendships, in your previous relationships with your parents, but with this one single person, this toxic love, suddenly you have all these anxious traits, all these avoidant
traits. You are terrified just for them, nobody else. One study I cited, actually in my book, and I still cited a lot, talks about how those early experiences of your attachment style being shifted by one singular relationship can take somebody who has had an overflowing amount of love in childhood, who is deeply cared for and just completely twist them into someone who, I don't know, acts like the survivor of childhood trauma, especially if this was their first relationship or their first significant relationship. Parents aren't the only one and aren't the only blueprint for how we think love should look. Young love, early love is also a milestone and is also a core bonding and learning experience that can, I guess, twist your interpretation of the behaviors that are normal in a relationship
and what a relationship should make you feel like? Should it make you feel safe and happy? Or should it make you feel anxious and hostile? If you've noticed yourself becoming more anxious and more hypervigilant after being in a relationship that was chaotic or with somebody who was just like impossible to read, it's likely that, you know, this is what's happening to you. Your nervous system has been changed by that relationship, your attachment system has been changed by that relationship,
and your attachment system is doing what it has evolved to do. It is trying to teach you how to best bond with other people so that you don't get hurt. and in this situation you were hurt. That doesn't mean that every situation is going to be like that, but this is why your brain learns to prevent things from the past happening again, and it makes generalizations. It makes you believe that every other love you're going to encounter in your life must look the same.
But I think that if our attachment style and our nervous system and all these other bonding systems can change to become more alert and more anxious and more avoidant, it's only right and it only makes sense that they can also change in the other direction. And that when the right person comes along, or maybe not even the right person, just a really kind person comes along, that can shift us into being more secure and feeling safer as well. Relationships can also increase a sense of security over time. There is so much evidence out there that partners can actually co-regulate each other. other, that healthy love, if we push through maybe some of the feelings of boredom or feelings of
fear and anxiety over the past, healthy love can heal us in a very unique way. And I know there's definitely this ongoing narrative that anything you don't heal before a relationship will harm that relationship. But I also think that, I don't know, I just don't always believe that. I think love is, very healing and sometimes the wounds left by previous situations, sometimes the wounds left by love can be treated by nothing else, not to be poetic about it, but, you know, that is the thing that we'll, I don't want to say fast track your healing, but I think that it's something that can be very beneficial if you've gotten to the state of pessimism and hostility towards relationships, not to say get back out there and get back on the horse,
fear and anxiety over the past, healthy love can heal us in a very unique way. And I know there's definitely this ongoing narrative that anything you don't heal before a relationship will harm that relationship. But I also think that, I don't know, I just don't always believe that. I think love is, very healing and sometimes the wounds left by previous situations, sometimes the wounds left by love can be treated by nothing else, not to be poetic about it, but, you0|||这是一个由 I-Heart 主办的播客。“绝对真人”。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个充满现代奇观的世界里，我将为你剖析精神坚韧、体能锻炼以及培养韧性的秘诀。
but sometimes the thing that you're avoiding doing the most and the thing that you fear the most and the reason you fear relationships the most is the reason you should get back out there so as not to maintain this avoidance and so as not to further indoctrinate this narrative in yourself that the only kind of love I'm going to experience is the unhealthy kind.
但有时候，你最想逃避的事情、你最恐惧的事情，以及你最害怕亲密关系的原因，恰恰是你应该再次去尝试的原因，这样才不会维持这种逃避心理，也不会进一步在心中强化这样一种观念：我将经历的爱情只有不健康的爱情。
And the only kind of people out there are the kinds that will hurt me or will hurt others. I'm telling you that is not the case. I'm telling you there are brilliant people yet to be discovered by you and many others. So what does that feel like? What does healthy love feel like? And how can we actually lean into that without like trying to fix ourselves with a relationship because that's definitely not what I'm saying?
以及外面的人都只会伤害我或伤害别人。我向你保证，事实并非如此。我告诉你，还有很多卓越的人等待着你去发现。那么，那种感觉是什么样的？健康的爱情是什么感觉？我们又该如何在不试图通过恋爱来修复自己的前提下去接受它呢？因为这绝对不是我的本意。
How can we just get some exposure to healthy love and know it when we see it? That's what we're going to be exploring after this show. go break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
我们如何才能接触到健康的爱情，并在看到它时就能认出它来？这就是我们在节目结束后要探讨的内容。休息一下。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，带你超越统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信植物油天生具有炎性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自我走出困境。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在MTV音乐录影带大奖上拍打莉尔·金胸部的那一幕吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集节目中，我们都会来到这里，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为国会。可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me,
我不认为还有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是...
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
你的主持人，你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct?
打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻之中。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。这就开启了长达数年的诉讼之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the Westby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·韦斯特比和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪，我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until Justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在这个新一季的《The Girlfriends》中，“哦天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。
Once you understand what toxic love has trained in you, I think the next question or reminder, I guess is what does healthy love actually feel like? And how do we practice recognizing it and staying in it long enough for our body to believe it and to believe that we are safe? I know you guys hopefully know a lot of this, so not to sound, don't want to sound patronizing. You don't want to sound patronizing or anything like that. But just because we have to, let's do a mini checklist of sorts around what is healthy love? Like a checklist that you could sit in front of somebody and be like, is that what we've got going on for us here? First up, healthy love is not built on guessing. If you ever, ever have to guess, does this person want to be with me?
一旦你明白有毒的爱在你身上训练出了什么，我想接下来的问题或提醒，大概就是健康的爱实际上是什么感觉？我们如何练习识别它，并在其中停留足够长的时间，让我们的身体去相信它，并相信我们是安全的？我知道大家希望对这些有很多了解，所以不想听起来，不想显得居高临下。你不想显得居高临下或类似的事情。但仅仅因为我们必须这样做，让我们做一个关于什么是健康的爱的小检查清单？就像一个你可以坐在某人面前说，这就是我们在这里发生的事情吗？首先，健康的爱不是建立在猜测之上的。如果你曾经、曾经不得不去猜想，这个人想和我在一起吗？
Does this person see us going in the same direction? Why haven't they labeled it? Why don't they like me back? me back, why wouldn't they include me in their plans? And you don't feel like you can clarify, that's not healthy love. You guys aren't in a relationship. Like, you do not have the essential ingredient. Yes, people take their time in relationships and people move at different speeds, but that position should be communicated. And so should their reasons. It's literally the most cliche thing you will see in every marriage book, every relationship book,
这个人觉得我们会朝着同一个方向发展吗？为什么他们不给它贴上标签？为什么他们不也喜欢我，为什么他们不把我写进他们的计划里？而你觉得自己无法澄清，那不是健康的爱。你们不是在恋爱。就像，你没有关键的要素。是的，人们在恋爱中需要时间，人们以不同的速度前进，但这种立场应该沟通。他们的原因也应该如此。这简直是你会在每一本婚姻书、每一本恋爱书中看到的最陈词滥调的事情，
communication is key. It's not that they won't commit right now. It's not that they don't know where you guys are going. It's that they're willing to talk to you about it. There is no confusion. The other thing healthy love or the beginnings of healthy love will often show you as well is that this communication we're talking about doesn't always have to end in an argument or something that's emotionally twisted or uncomfortable. I think that does actually become especially clear during these kinds of early on, what are we, what are we doing here, what do you want from me kind of conversations?
沟通是关键。并不是他们现在不愿意承诺。并不是他们不知道你们要去哪里。而是他们愿意和你谈谈。没有任何困惑。健康的爱或健康的爱的开始通常也会向你展示另一件事，那就是我们正在谈论的这种沟通并不总是以争吵或情感上扭曲或不舒服的事情结束。我认为这在这些早期阶段确实变得尤为明显，我们是什么，我们在这里做什么，你想要我什么这种对话？
When you have these conversations, I think a lot of the time, toxic love may have conditioned you to expect this rupture, this blow up, this dismissiveness, this silence, lies, icing you out, all these things that you've seen in the past, you begin to expect it. So a lot of the time I think we go into these conversations
当你进行这些对话时，我认为很多时候，有毒的爱可能已经让你习惯于期待这种破裂、这种爆发、这种冷漠、这种沉默、谎言、把你晾在一边，所有这些你在过去见过的事情，你开始期待它。所以在很多时候，我认为我们进入这些对话时
with a new relationship, in a new relationship with a lot of apprehension and nerves and anxiety. And then when nothing happens, when it's all calm and respectful, we're a bit like, huh, is that what that's meant to feel like? Honestly, sometimes that can feel like a trap. Like, oh, we've sorted this argument out. They've given me all the information. I need to know, where's the rest of this? Where's the rest of the drama?
带着一份新的感情，在一段新的感情中怀着许多担忧、紧张和焦虑。然后当什么都没有发生时，当一切都平静而尊重时，我们有点像，啊，这就是它的感觉吗？老实说，有时这感觉像个陷阱。就像，哦，我们已经解决了这场争吵。他们给了我所有的信息。我需要知道，这剩下的在哪里？戏剧性的其余部分在哪里？
The thing about healthy love is that sometimes, when you are arguing and when you are communicating and you're expecting the worst and the worst doesn't come, it's weird. It doesn't give these emotions a place to go because those emotions didn't belong in that space to begin with, but in the aftermath, like you've come in so hot and expecting something so terrible,
关于健康的爱，有时候，当你争吵时，当你沟通时，当你期待最糟糕的情况而最糟糕的情况没有发生时，这很奇怪。它没有给这些情绪一个去处，因为这些情绪本来就不属于那个空间，但在余波中，就像你带着如此激昂的心情进来，期待着如此糟糕的事情，
sometimes it can feel like you are unconsciously the one who is escalating things and like suddenly you're the toxic one in the relationship, if that makes sense, because I don't know if there's this whole stored up fear and anticipated anger that doesn't have an outlet. That was my experience at least. I had to learn how to fight with my partner. I felt like when I entered this relationship, I was spreading patterns from my past relationship because that was my operating manual. And it made me feel like, in the beginning, at least, like, am I the toxic one? Am I now becoming the person who, previously like hurt me. Some people call these survival behaviors. Some people call it emotional
有时你会觉得无意识中是你在升级事情，就像突然之间你成了恋爱中有毒的那个人，如果这有意义的话，因为我不知道是否存在这种积蓄的恐惧和预期中的愤怒，却没有发泄的出口。至少那是我的经历。我必须学会如何与我的伴侣吵架。我觉得当我进入这段关系时，我在传播我过去关系的模式，因为那是我的操作手册。这让我觉得，至少在开始时，我是那个有毒的人吗？我现在是不是变成了以前那样伤害我的人？有些人称这些为生存行为。有些人称之为情感
reactivity. I think the best label for this is just predictive processing. Your brain operates on a set of expectations determined by prior experiences and it's constantly trying to predict what's going to happen, what's coming for me, what's this fight going to end up like. And so it gets your body already and all hyped up for that situation, that anticipated situation. And then when it never comes, there's such a crash. There's a lot to unlearn because you basically have to stop predicting the worst case scenarios and the worst outcomes. And you have to remain open to a better scenario, which can leave you feeling really vulnerable and really unprepared when you're walking into these conversations with hope, being like, I really think I know, but what if I don't know and
反应。我认为最好的标签就是预测处理。你的大脑根据先前经验决定的一系列期望运作，它不断地试图预测将要发生什么，什么在等着我，这场争吵会以什么结束。所以它让你的身体为这种情况做好了准备，为那种预期的情境大肆炒作。然后当它从未来临时，会有如此大的崩塌。有很多东西需要摒弃，因为你基本上必须停止预测最坏情况和最坏的结果。你必须保持对更好情况的开放态度，这可能会让你在怀着希望走进这些对话时感到非常脆弱和毫无准备，心想，我真的认为我知道，但如果我不知道怎么办，
what if I should anticipate this worst case scenario, but I think the beautiful thing about healthy love is that you come into it maybe with fear and then you come down together. You emerge knowing each other more. Honestly, and I really hope he doesn't mind me saying this, but some of the moments I've just felt closest to Tom have been in the days after a fight because I feel like he knows me better and I know him better because everything was so raw, it was so honest. I never felt that way with any of my exes. Never.
如果我应该预料到这种最坏的情况怎么办，但我认为健康的爱美妙之处在于，你可能带着恐惧进入其中，然后你们一起平静下来。你们在更多地了解彼此中浮现出来。老实说，我真的希望他不介意我这么说，但我对汤姆感觉最亲近的一些时刻，正是在争吵之后的几天里，因为我觉得他更了解我，我也更了解他，因为一切都是那么赤裸，那么诚实。我和任何前任都没有过这种感觉。从来没有。
It was just panic. Panic for days and I remember I used to mute their messages and then unmute them and then mute them again. And I would turn my phone off and I would like check it again and just in case they had messaged me. And it was this whole toxic pattern of like I knew that getting into a fight and bringing things up, would mean that we wouldn't talk for days. And it would always feel like my fault. You know, this one particular X I'm thinking about, I remember he literally forgot it was my grandfather's funeral, and that was my fault. I remember saying, and I've said the story, so it doesn't hurt anymore, but I remember telling him, I loved him, and he told me he was going on a date with somebody else.
那只是一片恐慌。恐慌了好几天，我记得我过去常常把他们的消息设为静音，然后再取消静音，然后再设为静音。我关掉手机，然后又查看一遍，以防他们给我发了消息。这是一个整体上有毒的模式，就像我知道一旦发生争吵并提起事情，就意味着我们几天都不会说话。这总是感觉是我的错。你知道，我正在想的这个特定的前任，我记得他甚至忘了那是我祖父的葬礼，那是我的错。我记得说过，而且我已经说过这个故事了，所以它不再痛了，但我记得告诉他，我爱他，他告诉我他要和别人约会。
And we had this big argument, and that was my fault. I remember, like, if he had an emotional outburst, if he said something rude, that was still my fault. how? I don't know. I always justified it back then than it was, but healthy love, on the other hand, you know, it's just, it's just very easy and it's very quiet. And there isn't this blame game. Sometimes people describe it as feeling, because of that, like almost too calm, like something is missing. It's too quiet. And that can bring up a lot of anxious questions about settling and questions about compatibility, like, shouldn't there be a spark? Shouldn't I feel electricity? Isn't the a sign that we like each other, that we're willing to like push through together.
我们大吵了一架，那是我的错。我记得，如果他情绪爆发，如果他说粗鲁的话，那仍然是我的错。怎么会？我不知道。那时我总是为它辩解，但另一方面，健康的爱，你知道，它只是，它只是非常轻松，非常安静。没有这种指责游戏。有时人们形容它有这种感觉，正因为如此，几乎太平静了，好像少了点什么。太安静了。这会引发许多关于将就和兼容性的焦虑问题，比如，不应该有火花吗？难道我不应该感到触电吗？这难道不是我们喜欢彼此、愿意一起坚持下去的信号吗？
But I always used to question that and I still question that. You know, was it really a spark or was it just anxiety masquerading as excitement? Was it really a spark or like is this just this feeling of anticipation without resolution? Is this really a spark or were you just fighting all the time? This thing that you think you're missing with this new person, I don't think it's a connection. because there's obviously something that's keeping you in this healthy relationship. I think what you're missing when you feel this like boredom or like, is this person not the one because we're not arguing and there's not that passion,
但我过去总是对此产生疑问，而且我现在仍然对此产生疑问。你知道，这真的是火花，还是只是伪装成兴奋的焦虑？这真的是火花，还是这只是没有解决的期待感？这真的是火花，还是你们只是在一直争吵？你认为你在这个新的人身上找不到的东西，我不认为这是一种联系。因为显然有什么东西在让你维持这段健康的感情。我认为当你感到这种无聊或者觉得这个人不是真命天子因为我们没有争吵也没有那种激情时，你所缺少的是
what you're missing is adrenaline. What you're missing is hypervigilance. And I think the funny thing about hypervigilance is that it can feel remarkably like presence and like you're really in tune with the other person because that's what hypervigilance does. It keeps your nervous system and your attentional systems on high alert, picking up on everything. That's not love, though. That's not love. That intensity is not the only thing that can make a relationship survive.
肾上腺素。你所缺少的是高度警惕。而且我认为高度警惕有趣的地方在于，它感觉非常像当下的存在，就像你真的与另一个人同频，因为这就是高度警惕所做的事情。它让你的神经系统和注意力系统高度戒备，捕捉一切。但这并不是爱。那不是爱。那种强烈程度并不是让一段关系存活下去的唯一因素。
Here are some things that it does need. Here's that continuation of that list we were talking about. What does healthy love feel like? Healthy love, amongst all those other things we've said, is also not conditional. It is not conditional on you being good or behaving in the right way to receive attention. Or they only treat you right if you do what they want you to. Or they only treat you right or give you what you need if you don't ask for too much. It is not conditional on some kind of behavior that works best for them. It's also a situation where there is equality. One person doesn't have more of the power. One person
这里有一些它确实需要的东西。这里是我们要谈论的那个清单的延续。健康的爱是什么感觉？健康的爱，除了我们所说的所有其他事情之外，也是无条件的。它不是以你表现良好或以正确的方式行事来获得关注为条件的。或者只有在你做他们想让你做的事时，他们才对你礼貌相待。或者只有在你不要求太多时，他们才对你礼貌相待或给你你需要的东西。它不是以对他们最有利的某种行为为条件的。这也是一种存在平等的情况。一个人没有更多的权力。一个人
isn't the one calling the shots and you know that you know that like each of you comes in equal there is not somebody in the situation who could completely destroy the other person because they are completely unattached and there's not one person who is in the situation who is willing to give everything and get nothing in return it's equal there is equal investment there is equal time spent there is equal, yeah, just respect. And I also just think it's meant to be fun. You know, healthy love isn't always easy. It's not like you don't have these bumps. It's not like you don't occasionally have doubts. Even looking at your parents, for example, if your parents are still together, or your grandparents, or if you think of an example of healthy love in your life, like, there are
不是那个发号施令的人，你知道的，你知道每个人都是平等的进入这段关系，这里没有那种可以完全摧毁另一个人的人，因为他们完全没有依恋，这里也没有那种愿意付出一切却一无所获的人，这是平等的。有平等的投入，有平等的时间花销，有平等的，是的，仅仅是尊重。而且我也认为它本该是好玩的。你知道，健康的爱并不总是容易的。并不是说你们没有这些坎坷。并不是说你们偶尔不会有疑虑。甚至看看你的父母，例如，如果你的父母还在一起，或者你的祖父母，或者如果你想想你生活中的健康爱的例子，就像，仍然有
still things that sometimes go wrong, but you are actually at the end of the day enjoying yourself in that relationship authentically. And you feel like you can be yourself. Here is something a therapist friend of mine actually reminded me that we have to be aware of though. Sometimes those things, all those examples of healthy love I just gave, they actually lose their appeal after toxic love. They don't feel the same way.
有时会出错的事情，但在一天结束时，你实际上在那种关系中真实地享受着自己。并且你觉得你可以做你自己。这里有件事，我的一位治疗师朋友实际上提醒过我们，我们必须要意识到。有时那些东西，我刚刚给出的所有健康爱的例子，在经历有毒的爱之后，它们实际上失去了吸引力。它们感觉不一样了。
They don't have the same kind of drive. We don't have the same drive towards them. I don't want to say our desire systems, but like our preferences after toxic love in many ways can change. And that's, you're definitely not responsible for how someone treated you, especially when you were so ready to give them everything. And you were so invested in the relationship. Like you're definitely not responsible for that.
它们没有那种驱动力。我们对它们的驱动力不同了。我不想说我们的欲望系统，而是说我们在经历有毒的爱之后的偏好在很多方面会改变。而且那，你绝对不负责别人是如何对待你的，尤其是当你准备好把一切都给他们的时候。而且你对这段关系投入了那么多。就像你绝对不为那负责任一样。
But sometimes those experiences can actually change what we find ourselves attracted to. Just based on patterns and what feels known. research including a recent paper published just last year, tells us that we love what feels familiar. And so if what is familiar is hot and cold behavior, if what is familiar is passionate, all-consuming chemistry and not much else, if what is familiar is major highs and major lows
但有时这些经历实际上会改变我们发现自己被吸引的东西。仅仅基于模式和熟悉的感觉。研究，包括去年刚发表的一篇最新论文告诉我们，我们爱熟悉的感觉。所以如果熟悉的是忽冷忽热的行为，如果熟悉的是充满激情、无孔不入的化学反应而没有别的，如果熟悉的是巨大的高潮和巨大的低谷
and the promise of potential and the promise of the chase, sometimes guess, what? Sometimes you can continuously feel drawn to that, even if rationally you know better. It's just your brain both being, both having adapted to this new kind of love and also feeling compulsively drawn to it because of how comforting it feels because it has the manuscript and it has the manual for that. Healthy love, it doesn't have the manual for that. Or maybe it did before but it's kind of lost it. That kind of feels outdated to you. So the last thing, if the last thing you experienced was this toxic situation, of course you're going to feel drawn to
以及对潜力的承诺和对追求的承诺，有时猜怎么着？有时你可能会不断地被其吸引，即使从理性上你知道得更好。这只是你的大脑既适应了这种新类型的爱，又因为它的安慰感而情不自禁地被其吸引，因为它有那个剧本，并且它有针对那个的手册。健康的爱的，它没有针对那个的手册。或者以前有过，但有点弄丢了。那种对你来说似乎过时了。所以最后一件事，如果你的经历是有毒的局势，你当然会觉得被吸引
that because at least you know how it ends and at least you know how the storyline goes. I will also say, and this is a hot take I have, I honestly think that people who are very intelligent and are high achievers are often more susceptible to that kind of chase me, hard to get type behavior because they are used to feeling like if everyone else can have it, it's not worth having. And they're used to this feeling of like, if something is really worth it, it will make me chase it a little bit. And it should be a little bit out of reach to test me. And so sometimes those relationships that feel very like based on potential that ask you to work, it feels like they're just asking you to work a little bit harder. And it feels like
因为至少你知道它是如何结束的，并且至少你知道故事情节是如何发展的。我还要说的是，这是一个我持有的热门观点，我老实说，非常聪明且成就很高的人往往更容易受到那种“追我”、“难搞”类型的行为的影响，因为他们习惯了这种感觉：如果其他人都能拥有它，那就不值得拥有。而且他们习惯了这种感觉：如果某事真的值得，它会让我稍微追逐一下。而且它应该有点遥不可及来考验我。所以有时那些非常基于潜力、要求你努力的关系，感觉就像它们只是要求你更努力一点。并且感觉
they're more desirable because you can't get it easily. And it's like this weird, I don't know, capture or like achievement drive you have. Like, why would I want the easy thing when the hard thing, surely it's going to be more valuable because it's making me work harder. Like that effort is a sign of value. This may be a hard truth to swallow, but as much as you should be cognizant of other people's intentions when you are encountering or dating again after toxic love, you also have to question your own intentions as well. Are you just replicating what you have experienced in the
它们更有吸引力，因为你不能轻易得到它。这就像这种奇怪的，我不知道，捕获或者说成就驱动力。当困难的事情肯定更有价值因为它让我更努力时，我为什么想要容易的事情呢？就像那种努力是价值的标志。这可能是一个难以接受的真相，但正如你在经历有毒的爱后重新遇到或约会时应该对别人的意图保持警惕一样，你也必须质疑你自己的意图。你只是在复制你经历过的过去吗？
past? Are you just self-sabotaging here? Are you just giving or are you not giving the right people a chance because of past patterns and what you've learned from previous relationships? You have to be aware of other people's behavior, definitely, but you also have to be aware of how you're maybe behaving. And I think a big part of that is just giving, give Giving yourself more time to date slowly. Giving yourself time to be honest. This person I'm falling for, do they match the old blueprint or the new blueprint for healthy love that I'm setting for myself?
你只是在自我毁灭吗？你只是在因为过去的模式和从以前的关系中了解到的东西而没有给对的人一个机会吗？你必须意识到别人的行为，当然，你也必须意识到你可能在如何行事。我认为其中的很大一部分只是给予，给予自己更多的时间去慢慢约会。给自己时间去真诚。我爱上的这个人，他们符合我为自己设定的健康爱的旧蓝图还是新蓝图？
Are there behaviors the kind that I really want in a partner or just the kind that I'm used to? After toxic love, you know, there is this real urgency, often this real sense of like, pedal to the metal to like lock down a relationship or like as soon as you meet somebody you really like to push for commitment. You know, you feel like you want to fuse very quickly. You feel like, you know, maybe you've been strung along in the past. This previous relationship was really hard on you. So anything that can give you a sense of reassurance that this person isn't going to do that, constantly texting,
这些行为是我真正想要的伴侣的那种，还是只是我习惯的那种？在经历有毒的爱之后，你知道，有一种真正的紧迫感，通常有一种“油门踩到底”的感觉，想要锁定一段关系，或者一旦你遇到一个你真正喜欢的人就急于承诺。你知道，你会觉得自己想很快地融合。你会觉得，你知道，也许你在过去曾被敷衍过。这段过去的感情对你来说真的很艰难。所以任何能给你带来安全感的东西，比如这个人不会那样做，经常发信息，
constantly sharing, becoming exclusive immediately, being really vulnerable. That can create like this artificial connection and closeness so that, you know, unconsciously, you know, they won't walk away. That's a real habit I see. Or you, like, find yourself kind of playing games or, not even games, but, like, being very protective or, like, doing things that you know you shouldn't be doing just because of anxious patterns. You have to be aware of that, and you have to be able to interrupt that before it becomes a more entrenched pattern of behavior. Let's just, try getting to know somebody across time and very, very slowly. Let's just take how you would normally approach that relationship and dial it back a few paces and a few kilometers. Just after
不断分享，立即变得排他，变得非常脆弱。这可以创造出这种人工的连接和亲密感，以便（你知道的）在潜意识里，你知道他们不会离开。这是一个我看到的真实习惯。或者你发现自己在玩游戏，甚至不是游戏，而是非常具有保护性，或者做一些你知道不应该做的事情，仅仅是因为焦虑的模式。你必须意识到这一点，并且你必须能够在它演变成更根深蒂固的行为模式之前打断它。让我们试着随着时间非常、非常缓慢地去了解某人。让我们把你通常对待那段关系的方式收回几个步伐和几公里。就在
toxic love, if you meet the right person, if you meet a person who you think is really great, appreciate and pursue the slow burn and treat it almost like you are gathering information or that you are conducting kind of like a study in those first couple of weeks or months as well as dating. I think a helpful way to safeguard yourself from this like zero to a hundred love bond in the early stages of dating is to actually just break up time between your dates and to just not make them the center of your whole world. If you've been conditioned, into thinking that the only worthwhile connection is an immediate one and is those intense bonds where like your mind is immediately sure they're the right person and filled with hope and you're
经历有毒的爱之后，如果你遇到了对的人，如果你遇到了一个你认为真的很棒的人，去欣赏并追求慢热，几乎把它当成你在约会的前几周或几个月里收集信息或进行某种研究。我认为保护自己免受约会初期这种从零到一百的情感纽带伤害的一个有用方法，实际上就是打破约会之间的时间，不要让他们成为你整个世界的中心。如果你一直被塑造成一种思维定势，认为唯一值得建立的连接是即时的，是那些强烈的纽带——你的大脑立即确信他们是正确的人，充满希望，你对他们感到兴奋，你把所有的的时间都花在他们身上，就像这团令人难以置信的充满激情的火——那就尽你最大努力拉开约会之间的间隔。尽你最大努力真正给自己时间来进行现实检验。这真的是这里正在发生的事情吗？还是仅仅是新开始的激情？约会之间至少留出一整周的时间。而在那一周里，尤其是在最初的几个月里，不断地问自己，我在他们身边感觉更像我自己吗？我觉得我需要改变我自己的任何方面吗？我觉得很踏实还是他们让我感到焦虑？他们让我感到焦虑吗？他们让我觉得很低落吗？那是他们还是我在投射？我感到平静还是狂热？关系中的什么让我有这两种感觉？但特别是
excited by them and you spend all your time with them and it's just like this incredible passionate fire try your hardest to space out the dates try your hardest to just really give yourself the time to reality check. Is that really what's happening here? Or is it just the passion of a new beginning? Leave at least a full week between dates. And during that week, especially in the early months, continuously ask yourself, do I feel more like myself around them? Do I feel like I have to change anything about myself? Do I feel grounded or do they make me feel anxious? Do they make me feel anxious? Do they make me feel very low. And is that them or is that me projecting? Do I feel calm or do I feel frantic? What is it about the relationship that is making me feel either of those things? But especially
如果你感到狂热，努力去识别。而这绝对是我必须要做的事情。我感到狂热仅仅是因为这些天爱情很可怕吗？还是我因为他们行为中的某些东西而在我体内制造了这种狂热？还有，这是一个需要问自己的重大问题，你真的对他们感兴趣吗？你真的对他们好奇吗？还是你只是在追求安全感？这只是因为你喜欢这种注意？这只是因为他们也喜欢你？给自己时间。真正去思考答案和关系的真相。然后，晚些时候，你知道，如果事情进入了一个更确定的阶段，遵循六个月规则。如果你非常倾向于将你的生活
if you're feeling frantic, work to identify. And this is something I definitely had to do. Am I feeling frantic just because love is scary these days? Or am I feeling frantic because of something in their behavior that's creating that in me. And also, and this is a big question to ask yourself, are you actually into them? Are you actually curious about them? Or are you just chasing reassurance? Is it just because you like the attention? Is it just because they like you back? Give yourself time. Time to actually sit on the answers and the truth of the relationship. Then, later, you know, if things move into a more established thing, follow the six-month rule. This is really key if you are very much prone to merging your life
与某人和一个恋爱对象融合，这一点真的很关键。在六个月的时间里，推迟任何重大的决定。任何重大的决定，同居、养宠物、做出财务承诺、围绕他们规划你的未来，甚至去旅行，给它六个月的时间。在六个月的门槛上，然后你可以对这要去向何方做出决定。把一切都慢下来。给自己空间和时间去评估。给他们时间向你证明自己。我觉得这个策略，即使一开始感觉很不自然，我也认为它非常奇妙，因为它能让你更多地品味这个爱情故事。你知道，假设这个人就是对的人，特别是如果你在20多岁的时候，你知道，你余下的生命都可以和他们在一起。
with somebody and with, you know, a love interest. For six months, just put off any big decisions. Any major decisions, moving in, getting a pet, making financial commitments, crafting your future around them, even traveling, give it six months. At the six months mark, then you can make a decision around where this is going. Slow everything down. Give yourself space and time to assess. Give them time to prove themselves to you. I feel like this strategy, even if it feels unnatural at first, I also think that it's pretty marvelous because it lets you savor the love story a little bit more. you know, say this person is the one, especially if you're in your 20s, you know, you have the rest of your life to be with them. 50 to 60 plus years maybe, you know, you have the rest of your life for those big bold moments.
50到60岁以上，也许吧，你知道，你余下的生命都将用于那些巨大而大胆的时刻。但那前六个月，三到六个月，你们只是对彼此感到好奇，你们有这种神经过敏，你们对彼此感到兴奋，那不会永远持续下去。我只是认为你走得越慢，每个人都是赢家。你越能拉长那种真正美丽的初始感觉，你越能拉长那种真正美丽的初始感觉，你越能真正了解某人，你越能将你的焦虑缓和到这个新情况中，你越能摒弃模式，我从来没有听任何人说过，我后悔在关系的开始放慢脚步。没有人。我听过一堆人说他们后悔进展太快。我听过很多人说他们后悔匆忙度过蜜月期。我没有听到任何人说，我后悔花时间去真正了解
But those first six months, three to six months where you're just curious about each other and you have this skittiness and you're excited about each other, that doesn't last forever. I just think the slower you go, everybody wins. The more you get to draw out that really beautiful beginning feeling, the more you get to draw out that really beautiful beginning feeling, the more you get to really know somebody, the more you get to ease your anxiety into this new situation, the more you get to unlearn patterns, I've never heard anybody say, I regret going slow at the beginning of my relationship. Nobody. I've heard a bunch of people say they regret moving too fast. I've heard from a bunch of people who say they regret rushing through the honeymoon stage. I haven't heard anybody say, I regret taking my time and really knowing.
这个人，就像我了解一个朋友那样，或者就像我了解，是的，我认为一个朋友是表达这一点的最好方式，就像我了解一个朋友那样。不用急。如果他们是对的人，你有的是时间。好了，我们在这里要进行另一个短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，让我们从心理学的角度讨论更多接近健康的爱的方法，特别是在经历有毒的爱之后，特别是在你20多岁的时候。请继续收听。2%。那是同时也有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理坚韧性、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。
this person the way I would get to know a friend or the way I would get to know, yeah, I think a friend is the best way to say this, the way I'd get to know a friend. There's no rush. If they're the right one, you have plenty of time. Okay, we are going to take another short break here, but when we return, let's talk through some more ways to approach healthy love from a psychological perspective, especially after toxic love and especially in your 20s. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“回顾过去”播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
畅谈80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
我不认为有什么年份对黑人来说更重要。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。欢迎来到我的新播客“艰难学习”，我是
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me,
你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
以及与这么多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize
我们已经拥有了这件东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？
that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同信任水平。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我，基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客“艰难学习”中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
打开你免费的I-Heart Radio应用，搜索“艰难学习”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你对这个人篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试了一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑爆炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“爱情陷阱”。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这还没完。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“陷入爱情”播客。任何男人都应该遵守两个黄金规则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下姑娘。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在这个新季度的“女朋友们”中，天哪，这是同一个人。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man.
一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。所以她们把事情掌握在自己手中。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
他将得到他应得的。收听“女朋友们”。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我从过去的感情中发现的一个巨大的习惯是，把自己变小，这样更容易融入别人的生活，而不是看他们是否能以及能否融入我的生活。而这绝对是你需要摒弃的东西。有毒的爱往往会教导你，再次强调，爱是有条件的，并且以你对另一个人来说很容易为条件。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. A huge habit I found myself picking up from past relationships was making myself smaller so it would be easier to fit into somebody else's life rather than seeing if they would and could fit into mine. And that is something that you definitely need to unlearn. Toxic love often teaches you that, again, love is conditional and it's conditional on you being easy for the other person.
并且你遵循他们的指南或他们的准则。我认为当你在此之后遇到健康的爱时，你现在必须努力不让自己萎缩。夸耀你自己。要求更多。确保他们知道你期望成为优先事项。并确保他们知道你喜欢你自己。而且你很酷，你很不错，你很有趣。
and you following their guidebook or their guidelines. I think when you encounter healthy love after that, you now have to work on not shrinking. Brag about yourself. Ask for more. Make sure they know you expect to be a priority. And make sure they know that you like yourself. And you are cool and you are nice and you are fun.
你是一个他们会庆幸认识的人。你有着非常伟大的灵魂。你有着一颗非常博大的心，你期待着伟大的爱，这是一个很好的方法，可以剔除那些无法满足这些需求的人。是的，尽管我们想要缓慢而认真，但这并不意味着你不能表达你真正需要的东西。这是一个很好的方法。这是检验谁将无法达到标准并满足爱你的绩效指标以及融入你生活的绝佳试金石。我希望你们记住这一点，甚至将其作为对自己的肯定重复。
And you are somebody they would be lucky to know. You are a very big soul. you're a very big heart, you're expecting big love, that is a very easy way to weed out people who won't be able to meet those deeds. Yes, as much as we want to be slow and conscientious, that doesn't mean you don't get to express what you really need. And it is a great way. It's a great litmus test for who is not going to be able to meet the mark and kind of meet the performance metrics to love you and to like be in your life. I want you guys to remember this and even repeat it as an affirmation to yourself.
如果他们是那个对的人，他们会尽可能多地想要我。这不仅包括好东西。它包括情绪。它包括深度、界限、脆弱、困难的事情，甚至可能像是分歧，所有这一切。你值得拥有一份如此充实和完整的爱。它就像是要撑破缝隙一样。如果他们对此感到畏缩，如果他们无法处理，如果他们没有空间，我只是认为你们的生活并不一致。
If they are the one, they would want as much of me as they possibly could get. And that doesn't just include the good stuff. It includes the emotions. It includes the depth, boundaries, the vulnerability, the hard things, maybe even like the disagreements, all of it. You are a deserving of a love that is so full and complete. It is like bursting at the seams. If they cringe at that, if they can't handle it, if they don't have room, I just don't think your lives are aligned.
这不应该是你过度解读的任何事情。这不多也不少，只是你们不兼容。在经历有毒的爱之后，你必须继续相信美好的事物就在外面，即使感觉无助。这或许也包括，了解直接表达的重要性，这真的非常非常难。但对我来说，约会和爱情游戏在有了最戏剧性的转变，当我学会了仅仅说出我需要的
And it shouldn't be anything you read anything more into. It's nothing more or nothing less than this is just you're incompatible. You have to continue to believe after toxic love that big things are out there, even if it feels helpless. This also includes, I guess, knowing the importance of being direct, which is really, really hard. But dating and the love game, for me, had the most dramatic shift once I learned that just saying what I needed
因为我相信我自己，因为我想为自己争取更多，这会给我带来更好的结果。它彻底改变了我的约会生活和爱情生活。你知道我是怎么知道我的男朋友是对的吗？关于他的最后一个故事，我保证。那是当我们可能已经约会了
because I trusted myself and because I wanted more for myself was going to get me better outcomes. And it genuinely changed my dating life and my love life. Do you know how I knew my boyfriend was the one? And last story about him, I promise. It was when we had maybe been dating. for like a couple of months and he came over to my house and we were drinking apparel spritzes on my balcony and we went to dinner and at dinner I was like okay I'm going to give it to you
大约几个月，他来到我家，我们在我的阳台上喝着阿佩罗喷洒酒，我们去吃晚饭，在晚饭时我说，好吧，我要向你坦白
completely straight and I fully expected him to kind of be like I'm out but I didn't really I kind of knew right I was like but I just had to say it I was like I'm going to give it to you straight I'm looking for a relationship and that doesn't mean you have to promise one to me now that doesn't mean that like we need to go all in because we're taking it slow but if that is not your goal, just let me know now. And it was like, we'd had a lot of fun, we were two months in, if I was going to go any further, I just needed to be, I wasn't going to, like, I needed to be prepared and I needed to have my needs met. And I remember his reaction was a bit, he was a bit shocked, but he was like,
完全直接，我完全预料到他会说“我退出”，但我并不真的那样想。我有点心知肚明，对吧？但我只是不得不说出来。我说，我要跟你直说，我在寻找一段关系，这并不意味着你现在必须向我承诺一个关系，这并不意味着我们需要全力以赴，因为我们在慢慢来，但如果这不是你的目标，现在就让我知道。就像，我们过得很开心，已经两个月了，如果我要再进一步，我只需要，我不打算，我需要做好准备，我需要我的需求得到满足。我记得他的反应有点，他有点震惊，但他说，
all right, honestly, like, I'm all in, that's, we're on the same page. And that was early days. So I felt slightly uncomfortable, like coming to him with this demand being like, this is what I want, but I also knew that directness would scare away anybody who wasn't the one, because I'm a direct person, right? I'm somebody who really asks and likes what they want, so I wasn't going to go through that whole terrible situation again of hoping that he would maybe give it to me one day. I know a lot of us think that, like, the person we should end up with is would read our minds and we should be in complete sync with them and they should know exactly what's going on. with us and there's this emotional link, but, you know, the science isn't there yet.
好吧，老实说，我全力以赴，那是，我们在同一页上。那是早期。所以我感到有点不舒服，带着这个要求去找他说这就是我想要的，但我也知道这种直接会吓跑任何不对的人，因为我是一个直接的人，对吧？我是一个真正会询问并喜欢他们想要的东西的人，所以我不想再经历那种可怕的情况，整天希望他有一天能给我。我知道我们很多人认为，我们最终应该在一起的人会读懂我们的心思，我们应该与他们完全同步，他们应该确切地知道发生了什么。
I'm sorry to say, they can't read your mind. Sometimes they can't take the hint. You just have to be very utilitarian and direct about it and ask the answers you need, or ask the questions you need the answer to in order to move forward without playing coy and without playing games. I think my final slightly controversial thing, I will say when approaching healthy love after toxic love is just to actually question your gut instinct if it's telling you this person isn't the one and the only reason it believes that is because you feel bored. Trust gut instincts that say,
跟我们有关，这里有一种情感联系，但是，科学还没有达到那个地步。很抱歉这么说，他们不会读心术。有时他们听不懂暗示。你只需要对此非常功利和直接，并询问你需要答案的问题，以便在不装腔作势、不玩游戏的情况下继续前进。我想我要说的最后一个稍微有争议的事情是，当在经历有毒的爱之后接近健康的爱时，只要质疑你的直觉，如果它告诉你这个人不是对的，而它相信这一点的唯一原因是你感到无聊。相信那些说以下的直觉，
I don't think this person is a nice person. Trust gut instincts that say I think this person is using me, but especially after you've experienced toxic love, if there is a part of you that's like, oh, this person's just like a little bit too boring, or I'm settling or like, oh, I don't know, I feel like I should be more like really into them. Just pause. Pause for that intuition, that intuition only. I just think when you have become so used to, again, the major psychological games and the major psychological and emotional highs and lows
我不认为这个人是个好人。相信那些说我认为这个人正在利用我的直觉，但特别是当你经历过有毒的爱之后，如果有那么一部分的你觉得，哦，这个人只是有点太无聊了，或者我在将就，或者哦，我不知道，我觉得我应该更喜欢他们。只要暂停一下。为了那种直觉而暂停，仅仅是那种直觉。我只是认为，当你再次变得如此习惯于重大的心理游戏以及重大的心理和情感高潮与低谷时
of a toxic relationship, that feeling of calm can be unsettling. Because, not because, I should say, not because the relationship is wrong, bit because your interpretation of what it is and what is right for you has been kind of messed with. Take a moment. If you are feeling this right now and you're like, I can't tell whether it's just because of past experiences or because I am actually settling, just write down what is actually wrong with this relationship that is causing you to want to leave it. What about this relationship isn't working or living up to your expectations? And if the only answer you can
在经历了一段有毒的关系之后，那种平静的感觉可能会让人感到不安。不是因为——我是说，不是因为这段关系本身有问题，而是因为你对这段关系是什么、什么才适合你的理解已经被某种程度地搞乱了。花点时间想想。如果你现在正有这种感觉，并且觉得：“我分不清这究竟是因为过去的经历，还是因为我确实在将就”，那就写下来：这段关系究竟有什么问题，导致你想要离开它？这段关系中有什么地方是在失效，或者没有达到你的期望？如果你的唯一回答
give is I just feel a little bit bored or this just feels a little bit, like, it feels a little bit too easy or I feel like I'm settling, maybe just reassess and give it a little bit more time. And I know there'll be people coming at me being like, that's terrible advice, that's awful advice. I just feel like if there is nothing else wrong with this person, maybe give them a second chance. If that's the only thing you can think of. And yes, sometimes you'll do this exercise and you'll real. realize, okay, something is genuinely missing. And that's like actually an equally good outcome.
仅仅是“我只是觉得有点无聊”或者“这感觉有点……就感觉太轻松了，或者我觉得自己在将就”，也许你可以重新评估一下，再多给自己一点时间。我知道会有人来反驳我，说这是糟糕的建议，是可怕的建议。我只是觉得，如果这个人身上没有其他毛病，也许可以给他们第二次机会——如果这就是你能想到的唯一问题的话。是的，有时你做了这个练习后会意识到：好吧，确实有什么东西缺失了。这也是一个同样不错的结局。
Like, I think whatever clarity this gives you, healthy love does still need chemistry and it does still need alignment. But if you have alignment and if you do enjoy them and it's just because you're bored and they're otherwise a really nice person and they're really incredible and they really make you feel great about yourself and you're having a lot of fun, stick with it. just stick with it and see how it goes. Worse comes to worse, you end up being with somebody for a little bit longer who treats you really well
我觉得，无论这种清晰感带给你什么，健康的爱确实仍然需要化学反应，也确实仍然需要默契。但如果你有默契，如果你确实喜欢他们，而这只是因为你觉得无聊，除此之外他们真的是个非常好的人，真的很不可思议，真的让你对自我感觉极好，你们也过得很开心，那就坚持下去。就坚持下去，看看结果如何。最坏的结果无非是，你和一个对你非常好的人多相处了一段时间，
and allows you to move back into like a secure pattern and a secure way of seeing love. Worst comes to worse, you know, it doesn't work out, but at least you have this example that there is somebody out there who was really amazing and will treat you well and will give you what you need, even if it's not like, even if it's not,
并且让你能够重新回到一种安全的关系模式和一种安全的爱情观中。最坏的结果也就是，你知道的，这段感情没能走到最后，但至少你有了这样一个例子：这世上确实有人真的很棒，会好好对你，会给予你所需的东西，哪怕它最终不是、哪怕它最终没能
it doesn't end up being the one. Just those examples of love, I think are really, really brilliant. So give the easy and safe love a second chance. If your intuition is going wild with it, maybe question how your intuition has been shifted by emotional chaos. I hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope it has been a good,
成为那个对的人。我觉得，仅仅是拥有这些关于爱的范例，就已经非常非常美妙了。所以，给这份轻松和安全的爱第二次机会吧。如果你的直觉因此而疯狂拉响警报，也许你应该质疑一下，你的直觉是否已经被情感上的混乱所扭曲了。希望你喜欢这一期节目。我希望这是一个很好的、
honestly introduction into what toxic love may or may not do to us and how it changes us. There was a lot of rambling going on and I'm sorry. So if you have made it this far, I do very much appreciate it. And I hope that whatever situation you are in, you're doing all right and that you are feeling more and more optimistic by the day about there being wonderful love out there for you. Maybe it's not the one just yet, but I hope you're feeling more optimistic that they're just good people who will love you well and that you do have a lot of options and that you are deserving of wonderful things even if this past situation has made you think that everybody's out to get you or like everybody's out to hurt you or all love ends I promise that is that's not the
坦诚的引子，带大家了解有毒的爱情可能会或不会对我们造成什么影响，以及它是如何改变我们的。刚才我说了很多车轱辘话，对此我很抱歉。所以，如果你能听到这里，我真的非常感激。我希望无论你身处何种境况，你都一切安好，并且对未来能遇到美好的爱情一天比一天更有信心。也许他现在还不是那个对的人，但我希望你能更有信心相信，世界上依然有好人会好好爱你，你有很多选择，你值得拥有美好的事物——哪怕过去的情况曾让你觉得所有人都在针对你、所有人都在伤害你，或者所有的爱都会走向终结。我向你保证，事实并非
case why would we have so many beautiful love stories there's always hope out there and I don't think it's necessarily the thing that kills us all the time I think it's it's a healthy to be optimistic about the future of romance and and about finding someone who's incredible. So again, I hope you enjoyed this episode. If you are listening on Spotify or Apple Podcasts, make sure you give us a five-star review. If you're in the US or Canada,
如此。为什么会有那么多美丽的爱情故事？希望永远都在，而且我不认为爱情必然总是那个毁灭我们的东西。我觉得，对浪漫的未来抱有乐观态度，并去寻找一个不可思议的人，这是一件很健康的事。所以再次说明，希望你喜欢这一期节目。如果你是在 Spotify 或 Apple Podcasts 上收听，请记得给我们一个五星好评。如果你在美国或加拿大，
you can also watch on Netflix. So if you like video podcasts and you want to check this one out, go and watch it there. I feel like it brings a whole new vibe. If you've ever wondered what I look like and you've only ever seen or heard my voice, there's a good opportunity for you to go and, I don't know.
你也可以在 Netflix 上观看。所以如果你喜欢视频播客并想看看这一期，去那里观看吧。我觉得这带来了一种全新的氛围。如果你曾好奇我长什么样，而你之前只见过或听过我的声音，这是一个绝佳的机会去……我不知道，
it's kind of weird go and judge my appearance, but no, just go and check out the studio, check out the vibes. It's a nice, calm, peaceful set, a very nice, calm, peaceful video podcast. So, yeah, tell me what you think about it. Make sure as well you're following us on Instagram. You can also get transcripts of these episodes on our substack. If you are subscribed over there, I would really recommend it. You get cool articles in your inbox a couple times a week for you to expand your
去对我的外表评头论足感觉有点怪，不过不用那样，就去看看录制工作室，感受一下那里的氛围吧。那是一个很好、很平静、很安详的布景，一个非常不错、平静且安详的视频播客。所以，是的，告诉我你的想法。也别忘了在 Instagram 上关注我们。你还可以在我们的 Substack 上获取这些节目的文字稿。如果你在那里订阅了，我真的非常推荐。你每周可以在收件箱里收到很酷的文章，用来拓展你的
information horizons and your knowledge horizons. Thank you as always to our researcher Libby Colbert for her help with this episode. She's incredible and she did an amazing job researching a lot of that neurobiological and neurochemical, those neurochemical interactions we were talking about. So we appreciate her greatly. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
信息视野和知识视野。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的帮助。她太棒了，在研究我们刚才讨论的那些神经生物学和神经化学互动时，她做出了非常出色的工作。我们由衷地感谢她。但在此之前，请保持安全、保持善良、对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，如何培养精神坚韧度、保持体能以及建立韧性。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。“我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎症性。”我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称是两个字母“T-W-O”加上“Percent”，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不在乎黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊 80 年代可卡因的节目。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of cross. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊可卡因的事，只要你们想听。我是说，马克，这是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。所以我开始发现这里面有一条贯穿的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病这个话题摆到了桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人而言。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine,
基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给了大家。我说的是，特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、
Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某个目标时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在盲目追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能发自内心地去做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，与我基尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她言词中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。“你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吧？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。“我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。”阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子——
Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束——
served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
在亚利桑那州。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一：永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二：也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我是安娜·西恩菲尔德（Anna Sinfield）。在这季全新的《The Girlfriends》中，“天呐，这就是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。“我觉得自己就像被卡车撞了。”“我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？”警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他一定会得到他应得的下场。收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在当今这个奇妙的现代世界中，如何培养精神坚韧度、保持体能以及建立韧性。经历一些艰难困苦，你会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称是“TWO.%”，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何
84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
你获取播客的地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。对 1979 年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。84 年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人而言。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, podcast or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试结果，对吧？”“我篡改了一次测试。”
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scott. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一支网络侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子——格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科特。随着节目继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriend. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app,
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他一定会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》，在 iHeartRadio App、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方。这是一档 iHeart 播客。纯正人类制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。